when you came out here two years ago and
I think I just briefly heard you say you
you did some lifestyle rearranging or
something like that so was there a
moment or something that triggered you
saying I need to be more on track and I
need to devote a hundred and whatever
percent to my acting career rather than
when I came out here and it seemed like
more fun and games right yeah so coming
from New York to LA there's a big
difference in terms of the prior the
priorities that are in place or at least
the perceived priorities that are in
place and in terms of what are what's
important in your career and what are
the things that that need to be at the
top a-list in in New York it and again
these are implied so it's not as if this
is a explicit thing that's handed down
by anybody but in New York it seemed
there was a real emphasis on training
technique and and and craftsmanship and
in LA moving here initially it seemed
like the priority was really on profile
and and who you're hanging out with how
you spend your time what parties you go
to who you know these sorts of things
and I I mean I'm guilty of falling into
all those traps initially and I thought
you know it's these there are these
things that are sort of they appear they
look very similar to success and they
feel very similar to success as well
rubbing shoulders with certain people
you know being involved in certain
conversations you know being privy to
certain knowledge but but ultimately
it's it's sort of a sort of like a
mirage in the in the desert because
you're not really left you're still left
thirsty at the end of day and and you
find that those relationships are are
temporary temporary at best and and so
for me yeah it really took a paring down
of my life
it really took me simplifying in every
Nall aspect to really to really get the
work where I wanted where I want it to
be and where I want it to stay and it's
a sacrifice but I think that
going back as long as humans have been
been around I mean you had a sacrifice
they got a sacrifice for for what you
want would you say you've had to become
more of a lone wolf tops excuse the
expression but yeah I mean yeah I mean
if I said that you would say yeah no
absolutely I mean I think that that's
the exact term that you have to be you
know it's funny because I don't look at
LA and Hollywood as a place that I'm
necessarily but you necessarily make a
life per se it's more I hesitate to use
this simile but it's more like a like a
more of like a battleground of sorts in
the sense that you know you're here to
accomplish an objective and you're here
to be the best that you can be and
hopefully you're here to do the best
work that you can do and that's and that
those being your priorities and with
that in mind you know anything that
anything that detracts from that I mean
really has to go and so I think you
really have to to hold a very bright and
very honest light on your life and and
ask yourself is this this habit is
behavior is this thought process is this
relationship serving you know ultimately
my goal and in my ambitions and if the
answer is no it's got to go it's easy to
be distracted by any kind of stupidity
and around your life and I think I'm not
from here but I think just Los Angeles
it's just such as so many people are
that I'm talking actors whatever is it
just like oh yeah I'm trying to do my
own work but then they just find any
kind of reason not to do it and so it's
all about dedication passion and
yourself you think even for me in
Montreal I just the only thing I do 24/7
I don't really have friends I have some
I picked them up one here in LA LA and I
just focus on the work because otherwise
it's so easy to just spread yourself
do you think if you knew how lonely it
is trying to do that you would have done
it years ago because I think people
don't realize how you end up isolating
yourself by focusing though that's how
you do okay
yeah this is a very off lifting question
yeah yeah I think it's one of those
things that you have to find like I've
always prided myself and finding comfort
and the uncomfortable and I think that
if you can if you can find a way to be
to be happy and whole and complete when
you're alone I mean you will be up your
strongest when you are alone now that's
right and and lights gonna have a hard
time rattling you if you can go if you
have a center that's your own and that
is uh and that it's 100% your own like
in defended says at one point you need
to be emotionally balanced and that's
exactly about it once you are balanced
you can deal if you can enjoy yourself
being lonely and you can make peace with
yourself then you can attack anything in
the world and you know you're gonna have
a strong I don't know but I'll tell you
there's a line that he wrote yeah in the
script that says you know things can't
be perfect all the time
and for me I'm not sure if that's line
you were going for but for me I cannot
tell you how many times I think that on
a daily basis or on a weekly basis
resiliency like you said the balance is
so important because because you're
gonna have everything thrown at you
you're gonna you're gonna wake up on the
day of your screen test and you're gonna
have a migraine or you're gonna have
food poisoning or you're gonna have a
fight with your significant other the
night before or you know you're gonna
show up you premiere and you're gonna
have you know you got dust in your eye
or something I mean it's just the way
it's gonna work and and if you can roll
with those punches you know and if you
can have that that strength inside you
can achieve anything now
you